my agent called me jeff jeff from icm
called me about it i wanted brother's
doing more combat hey they wanted you to
play sub zero i was like
set again subzero be sure yeah and uh
is this an audition or something or they
want me to tape something no they want
you to play subzero
and i it was i was it was like unreal it
was unreal feeling for me
i remember i i asked my son about it and
then i just shouted from my bedroom and
my son was in the living room said
hey hero my stun name's hero and if i'm
in the modern combat movie
which character you think fits me the
most you're like you
you you're sub-zero i was like no way
and then this is meant to be this is
meant to be and then
it was crazy it was crazy and one phone
call and i got the support from my son
and then i grew up playing sub-zero it
was
it was crazy it was one of the
highlights of my life i gotta stay
so when you play the video game you were
always like playing as sub-zero that was
your go-to character
i grew up playing uh i i played
sub-zero scorpion and kung lao but my
favorite character is always sub-zero
because
it's kind of like my friend always said
like oh this is this character is too
overpowered
because you just you know i remember
when i was a kid because the only
the biggest damage is you just you do
the uppercut so you freeze the opponent
first and then you just walk slowly to
them like nothing happened and then
boom and all the blood spilled and then
like quarter of the
the the health is just gone so you do
three times uppercut
after you freeze the opponent you can
like win the game so
it's very it's very op the gamer like to
say it
op what do you think of your fatality
moves in the movie
well um first time i watched the movie
when we during the
issue because we need to watch it again
after you know
we finished 2019 so we came back to
australia to october 2020.
i don't know and it was i was almost i
couldn't say anything i was like
oh my god oh my god this is so good
and then everybody did did an amazing
job and then
all the fights story and the final fight
you know the forest fight in the
beginning to be honest when you when i
when i was on set working i didn't
really think about how it's going to
turn out i just focus like
you know you know focus on the job
like i need i need to make sure that
everything is right so i'm
quite perfectionist so i don't want to
get distracted to see
i didn't even i really checked the
monitor to be honest because i trust
the action director and everybody there
so when i
watch it for the first time it was it
was it was crazy it was crazy feeling to
see
that i have high hope
the feeling that i have like i hope when
people see it
first time on the big screen or on hbo
max they feel the same
it feels like there's so much happiness
so much proud
and then you know it is unreal what was
it like when you
first put on like the full sub-zero look
and then you stepped on set and like
saw yourself for the first time like
what was that moment like
well i remember the first fitting it
looked
super awesome i took a picture a lot and
there's
like a selfie here and there and but i
couldn't walk
it was so heavy well i was like
this is literally like this looks really
really cool i tried to
how i'm gonna be able to fight because
all metal
here and there and i think almost like
seven to ten kilos
in total and then cappy can't be on our
custom designer
she said like don't worry we we have
this version like the original one and
we have another version
it's like not that heavy and then you
can fight
so because i was i was worried like how
i'm going to be able to fight in this
costume because there's all
armor here and there so yeah it's very
thoughtful from the
custom division that they they think
about it way before
and and then the the five costumes still
heavy but it's doable it's still doable
right like how am i gonna kick
i was like well there's there's a lot of
really great source material for for
these characters not limited to the 1995
movie which holds a very special place
in a lot of people's hearts
uh what are your thoughts on that movie
and what do you think the biggest
difference is between what we've seen
before and what we're seeing now
well when i watch the original one i
mean the first one
i was like it was super fun because i
grew up playing the game when you see
all the characters you played in a game
like on a big screen
i had so much fun i i love the movie
it's just it's just great
it's just great to see all the favorite
characters you see
now like you know and they're in a you
know
what they call it kind of alive but the
difference
the different compared to this one
probably because technology
of course obviously way different we can
do more we can stretch more
and give more but i think in this one
what the writer did the director our
creative did
which i think is is very sweet and and
great to the fans because they they
trace back to what
when they were when they're not when
they didn't have the superpower
like the story of a sub-zero scorpion
when they're not
the scorpion of sub-zero and almost the
character jacks
like what's his arm how they get the
powers that what
the gamers you know played in the game
so that journey is
that's the difference compared to the
original because it's all about
fun it's just like to see your favorite
characters alive but in this one you see
more you see more arc you see more story
you see you follow the journey of each
character your favorite character
so i think it's just something like that
in the movie is always
leave more memory live more uh
great yeah great great nostalgia
good nostalgia at the same time but you
you you invest and you feel the
character more
and then you you see sub-zero let's say
for example stop zero
not just a badass who control eyes but
you see
you know who he was before and then the
journey
and you cisco what happened to scorpion
so this type of
approaches always always
give more uh impressions to the fans and
to moviegoers in general
yeah i think that's the difference well
i'm out of time but i absolutely cannot
wait to see more you're fantastic this
movie's so much fun and i'm so excited
forever thank you
thank you ashley thanks so much have a
good one
get over here
if
you